die schweiz ein land im herzen europas
[Musik]
ein landwirtschaftlich vernetzt und
politisch unabhängig
[Musik]
stolz auf seine eigenständigkeit auf
seine werte tradition
es gibt sich weltoffen und ist dabei
erfolgreich
doch die beziehungen mit seinen ängsten
nachbarn mit der eu sind kompliziert
geworden
die politik in der schweiz befindet sich
in einem dilemma
[Musik]
in diesem umfeld mit einer äußerst guten
ausgangslage für die schweiz darf uns
die neuordnung von macht und einfluss
trotzdem nichts verborgen bleiben
die eu will die beziehungen mit der
schweiz neu regeln
sie will nicht dass sich die schweiz nur
die vorteile herauspickt
wir haben einen gemeinsamen binnenmarkt
von dem auch die schweiz profitiert wenn
wir verschiedene regeln hätten wäre das
nicht gerecht gegenüber unseren
unternehmen gegenüber unseren mitbürgern
der königsweg steht vor einer
bewährungsprobe
wichtige verhandlungen mit der eu sind
festgefahren etwa über das stromabkommen
ein wichtiger vertrag für die
schweizerische energiepolitik wir können
technisch kaum mehr weiter verhandeln
weil diese frage der grundsätzlichen
zusammenarbeit von im raume steht
die europafrage ist wieder aktuell 20
jahre nach dem schweizer nein zum ewr
und wie damals geht es um die frage der
identität das verstreichen der
eu-beitritt mitgliedschaft der revision
ramelow mit schlagworte gleichen sich
alte wunden reißen wieder auf für den
verhandlungen für eine eventuelle bietet
für eine fiktive novitec sie das gar
nicht mehr anders gegangen
das ist klar die usa aufgefordert ihre
machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist winter an den ufern des
bielersees und es wird ein nein gefeiert
ein nein zu europa nein zum ddr vor 20
jahren
im mittelpunkt des geburtstagsfestes
steht christoph blocher
der mann der ddr nein seinen politischen
aufstieg zu verdanken hat
[Applaus]
und er macht vor seinen anhängern europa
europa skepsis erneut zum politischen
thema übernahmen fremdenrecht ohne dass
die schweizerinnen und schweizer noch
bestimmen können auch damals hat man
gesagt dass ich gar nichts schlimmes
ständig die öffnung wir sind doch
europäer und dort verschwiegen dass es
ungerecht zugeht durch einen anderen für
unser land und das wird wieder kommen
hier geht es nicht nur um die rückschau
hier geht es um aktuelle fragen um
handfeste politik und darum reichte der
bundesrat auch damals das
eu-beitrittsgesuch rein und halte noch
liegt es dort in einer schachtel und ich
lebe an wenn die eu beamten an dieser
sache vorbei gehen jetzt in dieser
arbeitszeit werden sie vor sich hin
singen stillstehen wie das pure ali
schlaf war will
mit einer schweiz gewürdigt die wehrhaft
sein so die für ihre werte einstehen
muss
[Applaus]
mit dem gleichen symbolen wie damals vor
20 jahren
[Applaus]
vor 20 jahren
als die schweizer über den ewr-beitritt
abstimmten wurde hier oben in auf 2000
meter über meer deutlich nein gesagt als
anderswo er das weiß
[Musik]
severin lud sie war damals
gemeindepräsident alle 39
stimmbürgerinnen und bürger sagten
geschlossen nein
mizzi musste keinen in der gemeinde zu
meinen überreden
hübner der überzeugung dass er mehr in
tripolis und hat das bild einer partei
oder was das taxi das sie denn nicht
dass er deutlich
hier in münstertal in graubünden
arbeiten die meisten in der
landwirtschaft damals wie heute ein
leben angepasst an die verhältnisse in
den alten
[Musik]
zehn kilometer von der italienischen
grenze entfernt stehen die menschen seit
jeher im kontakt mit den nachbarn mit
italien mit dem südtirol weltoffen und
trotzdem für sich dass die bewohner von
juso deutlich nein sagten zu einem
wirtschafts vertrag lag in der angst
dass ddr etwas anderes folgen würde
wir sind am richtigen weg sie fliegt nur
der er selber wirklich nicht schlecht
für das münstertal mit der grenze aber
dreijährigen oder elbe sagte sie das ist
roddick sie genau diese angst vor allem
europa beitritt heizte die emotionen
[Applaus]
blind side mit blindheit schlagen was
mir an diesem standort zu bauen ist ein
bissiger hindu verschuldung durch
wünsche ich eine rede sein
doch hätten wir sie nicht die insel der
seligen zwischen armee kontrolliere mit
können
da funktionieren ohne dass wir irgendwie
mit dem bus land zu schaffen
die offizielle schweiz verfolgt damals
tatsächlich den beitritt als ziel ddr
ein wirtschafts vertrag hätte die
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen zwischen
nachbarn neu regeln sollen doch der
vertrag selber wurde nur als
zwischenlösung dargestellt und die angst
vor noch mehr europa schreckte viele
zurück
[Applaus]
christoph blochers nein-kampagne baute
auf dieser strategie auf und er stand
als großer sieger da ihnen ohne ego wir
mehr bürokratie sei jeden tag menschen
sein vortrag reverso paar millionen
franken für gesteckt
derzeit ist kurz und schwyz und aber wir
hatten unglaubliches engagement bessere
sicher verdreifachen wenn die ganze
schweiz alle flugblätter verteilt und
ohne portokosten verteilt mehr als netz
geld vom bürger wollte hand wo es zu fuß
gelaufen sind und die flugblätter
verteilten
das nein am sechsten dezember 1992
brachte eine zäsur in der
schweizerischen europapolitik
der beitritt zum europäischen
wirtschaftsraum scheitert am volks und
am ständemehr röstigraben vertieft das
welschland stimmt dem e werk la zu die
deutschschweiz lehnt ab es fertigt der
stimmberechtigten fiel deutlicher aus
als erwartet
16 von 23 ständen sagen nein zum ewr das
sind 49 7 jahr gegen 50,3 prozent nein
nur 23.100 und fünf stimmen
die abstimmung über den ewr-beitritt
veränderte die politische landschaft in
der schweiz
diese abstimmung teilte das land in zwei
welten in gewinner und verlierer würde
mal festhalten oder net neben dem
bundesrat stand auf der verliererseite
auch ein großer teil der wirtschaft
schweizer firmen haben sich viel vom
wirtschafts vertrag versprochen was
nicht immer noch berührt ist dass es
unter dem stichwort wenig komisch die
wirtschaftlichen faktoren im fokus
sondern hat immer mit politik also wenn
die wirtschaftlichen faktoren wo im
europäischen wirtschaftsraum galt
akzeptiert fördert und wünscht dass die
aufgewendet werden in als schlachter
schweizer als anti patriots bezeichnet
das finde ich einfach nicht gerecht
[Musik]
fritz fanny war vor 20 jahren chef des
winterthurer industriekonzerns sulzer
an der der mächtigen den
wirtschaftskapitäne der schweiz sein
konzern macht einen umsatz von 7
milliarden franken beschäftigte 30.000
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die
zeit damals war nicht nur für sulzer
turbulent große teile der industrie
wurden durchgerüttelt auch noch jahre
nachdem iwr nein verharrte die schweizer
wirtschaft in der stagnation
viele große konzerne lagerten die
produktion ins ausland aus brand die
frau ist nach wie vor hoch stand das
ende und dann über die bilaterale
abgesichert sind nutzt und hand in hand
allerdings rund ein jahr länger braucht
das 2 1
grease oder mangels wachstum aber es ist
trotzdem die verantwortlichen in europa
zeigten damals offen ihre verärgerung
es gibt kein bilaterale weg der schweiz
ob wir haben unsere konter aktuellen
abkommens dass das bleibt ich schließe
nicht aus dass wir das in zukunft
weiterentwickeln können
aber dass wir etwas bilaterales machen
mit schweiz nachdem der schweiz
verweigert hat die das gesamtkonzept zu
akzeptieren dass ich es völlig
ausgeschlossen
es hat jahre gebraucht um die eu vom
gegenteil zu überzeugen
zehn jahre nach der abstimmung traten
die ersten bilateralen verträge in kraft
auch die eu hat ein interesse mit der
schweiz verträge abzuschließen sie
wollte zum beispiel den transitverkehr
regeln
die zusammenarbeit mit der eu ausgebaut
worden mit den politischen kräften links
und rechts die konstruktiv und kreativ
wachen dieser weg haben will gebaut
steht bei schritt seit 1992 und mit dem
scheitern der serie wir waren nur mit
einem freihandelsabkommen mit dem mit
der eu damit einer alten von 1972 und
wir haben diese bilateralen beziehungen
gebaut und jetzt ist es ein wirklich
politisches projekt geworden und ich
glaube wir haben alle dasselbe interesse
unserer souveränität und eigenschaften
zu behalten
und dieser weg erlaubt ist
der bilaterale weg gilt seither als der
königsweg für die schweiz
[Musik]
120 bilateralen abkommen bilden an den
grundstein für das wirtschaftliche
wachstum der letzten jahre
die schweiz ist der drittwichtigste
wirtschaftspartner der ihn doch in
brüssel kehrt der wind die eu befürchtet
dass die schweiz mit den bilateralen
verträgen besser gestellt ist als ihre
eigenen mitglieder
sie will mit der schweiz ein
rahmenabkommen vereinbaren die verträge
dynamisieren wie es heißt die schweizer
und sich verpflichten in einzelnen
bereichen automatisch neues eu recht zu
übernehmen
unabhängige gremien sollen die
einhaltung der verträge überwachen
ex-premier und per notruf rust wir sehen
ein bisschen frustriert das habe ich der
schweizer bundespräsidentin so
mitgeteilt
denn es hat sich wenig getan in den
letzten jahren in bezug auf den
binnenmarkt der bundesrat überbrachte
der eu im frühling an den ersten
lösungsvorschlag
wir werden vorschläge machen wie wir zu
diesem ziel dass er dasselbe ist wie das
tierheim präsident barroso wie wir
meinen wir können zu diesem ziel kommen
immer auch unter berücksichtigung
unserer föderalistischen strukturen und
der kompetenzen die die kantone auch in
diesem bereich haben
h
die situation ist verfahren was die eu
nun verlangt ritzt am politischen system
in der schweiz an der direkten
demokratie
das war schon beim ew er ein zentraler
streitpunkt in der schweiz hat die
bevölkerung das letzte wort dieses
prinzip wäre teilweise ausgeschaltet
wurden
das hatte damals auch der bundesrat ein
gesehen
[Musik]
die politik in der schweiz stecke in
einem dilemma sagt der politologe peter
freiburghaus
wenn ihr mit stellgröße linie versetzte
und das wetab ästhetisch als
mitgliedstaat oder als norwegen
der begriff für die natürliche zähne
zeigen die heute nicht hat ein
bildermarkt praktisch vollen ganz denner
aldi vorteil hat aber am schluss wer
selber überwachen und und wetterberichte
und welche rechte mit übernahm es doch
nicht passt an sich geht das natürlich
nicht als inbegriff für die freundliche
frau ganz begriffen dass wenig getan
[Musik]
die situation heute ist vergleichbar mit
der situation vor mehr als 20 jahren mit
der zeit vor dem wdr also
auch damals ging es um eine
weichenstellung
[Musik]
auch damals befand sich europa im
umbruch
kalte krieg dient dem ende entgegen
der fall der berliner mauer stand bevor
grenzen öffneten sich
[Applaus]
die wende ließ europa stärker
zusammenwachsen
die geburtsstunde dieses neuen europas
war anfang januar 1989 der damalige
kommissionspräsident jacques delors
hielt im europäischen parlament eine
grundsatzrede die mobilität wird zu
einer unvermeidlichen tatsache die
technologie verändert unser tägliches
leben
er beschwor die neue europäische einheit
meine damen und herren europa kann die
rolle nur dann wahrnehmen wenn es seine
kräfte bündelt die heute noch so
verstreut sind und der lohe kündigte
auch einen gemeinsamen binnenmarkt an
auch für länder die nicht mitglied sind
und dann sagt er einen folgenschweren
satz
wir müssen eine organisation finden die
gemeinsame entscheidungs und
verwaltungsorgane hat gemeint ist der
iwf
[Musik]
in der schweiz im bundesrat hörte man
genau zu kurz zuvor hatte man sich grafe
den alleingang ausgesprochen
doch nun schien eine zwischenlösung
möglich dabei sein aber ohne beizutreten
und wichtig mitreden zu dürfen
es ist klar wenn es keine mitsprache
gibt sehen wir nur eine minimale lösung
soll es einen umfassenden vertrag geben
mit gegenseitigen kontrollmechanismen
bestehen wir auf der mitsprache um die
regeln zu bestimmen
die vorverhandlungen mit begannen
hingeht die mitgliedsländer der
europäischen freihandelszone efta
suchten gemeinsame position
doch schon als sich die delegationen an
den verhandlungstisch setzen merkten sie
dass das versprechen der europäer
gebrochen wurde eine mitsprache wurde
ihnen kategorisch verweigert
zahlreiche efta länder darunter
österreich wollten nun so rasch als
möglich der europäischen gemeinschaft
beitreten dynamik die aus brüssel
ausgeht brust ließ heute ein
gravitationszentrum hat schließlich die
ganze elfter in den bann gezogen und wie
immer alle efta länder müssen hier
beziehungen zu der eg schnell und solid
intensivieren
1991 bei den hauptverhandlungen in
brüssel wurde immer klarer dass wichtige
verhandlungsziele der schweiz nicht
erreicht werden die schweiz musste weit
mehr nachgeben
als sie ursprünglich wollte außer nach
verhandlungen über den gemeinsamen
binnenmarkt wurde ein kräftemessen die
europäische gemeinschaft wie die eu
damals hieß gegen die ft
weil viele efta staaten der eu beitreten
wollten stand die schweiz mit ihrer
forderung nach mitsprache allein auf
weiter flur
obwohl die verhandlungen in einem sehr
zivilisierten atmosphäre stattgefunden
haben
wo sich doch feststellen dass die
gemeinschaft ihre offerten verkürzt und
ihre forderungen verschärft
chefunterhändler franz blank hat führte
damals die verhandlungen für die schweiz
wo mehr hatte sollte es zur verhandlung
stracke und mit der andere ist dass der
bundesrat allerdings nicht dass man
entschieden dass ich verschwitzt
natürlich ein sehr entscheidender punkt
sie für die eu verlangt dass mir das
recht wo sie beschließt nach einem uci
übernahm mehr oder weniger ohne wenn und
aber das ist natürlich völliger
souveränitätsverlust was der schweiz
ohne pass tätig das nachher tev da hätte
die institutionen gerichten und
überwachungsbehörde endlich sophie
richter
das heißt es sich plötzlich wie marcel
supranationale organisation wurde oder
partner beschwerten sich über die sturen
schweizer
weil einige staatenvertreter das was er
seit langem bekannt ist dass es im
europäischen wirtschaftsraum nur ein
mitwirkungsrecht geben wir den
mitspracherecht aber keine mit
entscheidung
doch letztlich in frage stellen und
erzwingen wollen
ein mitentscheidungsrecht für die efta
länder das wird eh nicht zugestehen
das ist gemeint auf die schweiz das ist
vor allem ein anliegen der schweiz
ich war an einem nachtessen im mai 1991
gab der bundesrat seine forderungen nach
mitsprache auf und verlor auch den kampf
um ein veto recht
[Musik]
der bundesrat gab sich an diesem abend
geschlagen aussteigen aus den
verhandlungen war kein thema
[Musik]
doch was die öffentlichkeit nicht wusste
schon am 10
vier tage vor diesem entscheidenden 8
dessen in brüssel hatte der bundesrat
seine europa strategie geändert
auch er strebte jetzt einen eg beitritt
an
ich muss immer plan b h wenn man
defensiv nicht verlieren position mit
event charakter gegenüber dem schweizer
volk welche im schweizer volk können wir
sagen alle möglichkeiten offen halten
im dezember jahr zum ewr können wir
sicher nicht das gesuchte bietet
schweizer volk zum ewr nein denn der
staat den himmel ermöglicht sorgt die
als schlacht lofer in europa die schweiz
fünf monate später machte der bundesrat
den nächsten schritt
[Musik]
zunächst flogen die beiden für das iwr
de zuständigen bundesräte zur letzten
verhandlungsrunde nach luxemburg
die marathon sitzung endete am frühen
morgen des 22
oktober 1991 die letzten strittigen
punkte wurden aus dem weg geräumt
[Musik]
abgelöst werden
welche finanziellen aus nach drei jahren
verhandlungen war der vertrag unter dach
und fach
in der anschließenden pressekonferenz
lobten die schweizer bundesräte den
ausgang der verhandlungen
[Musik]
ich bin ein guten morgen einen morgen
der sich über einen völlig neuen europa
erhebt
ohne zweifel haben wir es mit einem
vertrag zu tun reicher nicht weiter
beziehung dem ideal bilden teilt dass
wir uns zu beginn davon gemacht hatten
danach um 3 uhr am morgen ließ rené
felber die katze aus dem sack hat
inzwischen entschieden diesen eba nur
noch als therapie anzusehen als
etappenziel ziel einer vollständigen
integration der schweiz bei der eeg
vergütung ration das mittagessen vom der
beiden bundesräte 3 4 verloren und ich
hatte das zu machen wenn man vorher
informiert hat der bundesrat der
rebellische der honig mich heute
akzeptieren für das paar jahre aber
eigentlich war das noch akzeptieren
im trainingslager der ewiges
trainingslager verbieten oder aus der
bundesrat hat subjektiv er versicherte
sturm max thoma gesehen dass das haus
wochen hat
[Musik]
selten zuvor hatte die regierung einen
solch gravierenden außenpolitischen
entscheid gefällt
ein vollbeitritt hätte das politische
system einschneidend verändert
für viele kam die ankündigung
überraschend iwf und eu beitritt die
parteien war nicht konsultiert worden
aus heutiger sicht sind die reaktionen
aus der wirtschaft überraschend positiv
sogar für die doppelstrategie süße 16
analogen im sinnvollen abschottet und
gar keinen umständen die frage eröffnete
werk von der schweiz ag das ist eine
chance um ins netz
da greift das wohlig führte
unterzeichnet er ist auf ihre zweite
schritt sofort nach wie vor der
kandidatur
denn hat man mit schweden und österreich
seien vorhanden wie ein apfel für uns
bestimmt nicht definitiv der neuen
vertrags revision und wer jetzt nicht
handelt mit dem zweiten schritt betritt
kandidatur wie hat die zuschüsse dies
über sie auch zeitungen sind auch
verschiedene parteien unterstützten
diesen weg das ist auch ein gutes omen
was den ewr vertrag betrifft der sicher
noch nicht abschließend ist der in bezug
auf mitbestimmung eben gewisse mängel
aufweist
und darum hat der bundesrat gut daran
getan diesen werfertag als etappe zu
bezeichnen folgen wird ein
beitrittsgesuch unsere partei steht zu
diesem weg
parallel dazu endlich eine weiteres
gesuch einreichen
und zweitens müssen wir nun endlich die
inneren reformen an die hand nehmen weil
eine weitere tat auch nachteil doch von
da an wurde die diskussion um den iwr
von der diskussion um den vollbeitritt
überlagert die wr gegner um christoph
blocher nutzten diese situation aus der
politik ein einheitliches ergebnis mal
ran an die damen und herren mit der
festen absicht sie rote blocher führte
statt eines abstimmungskampfs gegen
einen wirt schafts vertrag einen kampf
gegen den eu-beitritt die argumente des
bundesrats fanden wenig gehört innerhalb
der svp der partei ogs und blockhaus
geräten die befürworter ins
hintertreffen
die meinung in diesem kurs schon gemacht
ich hoffe ich habe noch eine chance der
zürcher flügel um christoph blocher
setzte sich durch
der 18 mai 1992 ein halbes jahr vor der
ewe abstimmung
der bundesrat beschloss das gesuch
definitiv abzuschicken
[Musik]
am morgen zwischen 6 und 7 hat der
bundesrat nach dem erfolg am wochende
brett und iwf akzeptiert vertrag vom
herr bundespräsident ferner beschlossen
wir möchten das gesuch um aufnahme von
beitrittsverhandlungen ihren entscheid
dem bundesrat an diesem 18 fiel denkbar
knapp aus
im verhältnis 4 zu 3 auch adolf ogi war
dafür erwerben
unmittelbar nach der sitzung vom 20
männer und der schwede hat in spittal
wie vizepräsident joe biden hat ein
vizepräsident präsidium und bestellung
skala bis dieser tempel klar mit dialekt
uhrig 7 hätte das kursverhältnis greifen
damit trotzdem 43 entscheidet am morgen
aber sympathie zum heidfeld mit der
krankheit spittaler mühe so maradona ist
etwas diffus kann nimmt das natürlich
hätte das alles belastet und daher
selber hat das gewünscht und biss ihm
helfen club vor
[Musik]
alle analysen des bundesrats hatten bis
dahin gesagt dass sein vollbeitritt mit
dem politischen ziel der schweiz nicht
vereinbar seien
innert kurzer zeit änderte der bundesrat
seine meinung radikal furchtbar ich habe
zu ihrer selbige gute flasche wieder mit
dem motto fischer soziales viel klarer
ein wirtschafts vertrag der ddr hätte
den einfacheren austausch mit den
nachbarstaaten erlaubt doch im laufe der
verhandlungen hat der bundesrat
eingesehen dass dieser vertrag mängel
hatte deshalb die doppelstrategie
zunächst aber musste noch das parlament
zum wirtschafts vertrag ddr ja sagen
hall problem wird die wahrung der
volksrechte sein ich bin der meinung
dass überall wo irgendwie ein
gestaltungsraum für die schweiz und für
der schweizer volk übrig bleibt das
gesetz zur verwendung gewahrt werden
muss also wir sind komplett dagegen dass
das referendumsrecht für 60 gesetze
aufgehoben werden das ist nicht nötig
die eg verlangt von uns das nicht und es
ist nicht nötig dass die schweiz mit
ihrem langsamen demokratischen system
jetzt die musterschülerin spielen wie
opposition kam von links bis rechts in
südeuropa zu unseren problemen
mitbekommen entwicklung heißt jetzt für
die schweiz zusammenarbeit und
solidarität mit europa unsere
grundsätzliche kritik am ewe abkommen
bleibt nach dieser debatte stehen
[Musik]
anpassen europäische gesetze autonom
vollziehen
hier wurde es ein erstes mal
durchgespielt gesetzesänderungen nur für
den fall dass das volk später ja sagt
die zeit drängt bis zur abstimmung im
dezember 1992 blieben nur wenige wochen
und die stimmung in der bevölkerung
kippte das nein zum ewr wurde tatsache
der sechste dezember wurde ein
historischer tag
der bundesrat bedauert dass die schweiz
den entscheid auf möglichkeiten zur
wohnungen entwicklung verzichtet und mit
der politischen tradition europa sie
extra politik traditionell auch für
bundesrat ueli maurer ist das ein
schwarzer sonntag für die hälfte der
schweiz und für die jugend der streit um
den rechten weg schien entschieden
das thema ewe ist von der politischen
landkarte verschwunden
doch nun will die eu den politischen
teil den institutionellen teil
durchsetzen
der teil der in der schweiz beim bdr
innenpolitisch zu heftiger kritik
geführt hatte der teil der bilateralen
verträgen von der schweiz ausgeklammert
werden konnte dass die abkommen start i
bliebe kenne die institutionen
überwachen
das ist ein vorteil und dort spielt sich
in ruhe das der bundesrat aber hätte die
eu werde die bitte des internets da mal
großzügig und sie zwar bemerkte dass er
das verbietet das gesetz aber mit einer
vorderen reihen institutionellen rahmen
damit stellen sich wieder die gleichen
fragen wie damals beim iwf
die frage der souveränität mitbestimmen
ohne dazu zu gehören
[Musik]
die suche nach neuen lösungen beginnt
schon heute werden europäische gesetze
in der schweiz automatisch übernommen
ich bin überzeugt dass wir auch ein
interesse haben mit der eu zu verhandeln
über institutionelle fragen damit wir
diese diese souveränitäts fragen besser
erklären können das heißt zum beispiel
wir möchten wie wir das in schengen
gemacht haben
wir möchten an der entscheidfindung auch
teilnehmen können einen einfluss haben
weiß souveränität heißt auch einen
einfluss haben in den entscheidenden
wochen sein können und für die für jetzt
haben wir das in schengen geschafft aber
nicht in den in allen unseren abkommen
mit der eu so wir haben auch ein
interesse mit der eu darüber zu
verhandeln
der bundesrat hat nun der eu
vorgeschlagen weiterhin den bilateralen
weg zu beschreiten
die heiklen fragen in einem
stromabkommen zu testen
es ist ein thema mit viel symbolkraft
die schweiz das land der berge die
schweiz das wasserschloss europas
hier hielt die schweiz 1992 einen trumpf
in der hand
damals ging es um die straßen
diesmal um die energie die eu will die
energiewende schaffen weg vom atomstrom
strom aus windrädern und
solarkraftwerken muss über weite
strecken transportiert und gespeichert
werden
für brüssel sind diese speicher ein
wichtiger teil der neuen
energiestrategie und hier kommt die
schweiz ins spiel
schon heute bauen die schweizer
stromfirmen solche speicher unter
anderem hier enorme trance in den
walliser alpen ihre geber hat ist bei
alpiq für die wasserkraft verantwortlich
also auch für die neuen kraftwerke in
den bergen
[Musik]
tief unten im berg werden stollen
ausgebaut
rohre verlegt pumpen installiert
doch er sagt natürlich die maschinen in
150 megawatt das geht seinen hund mit
der leistung entspricht demnach am
kauftag
der markt ist alpiq investiert hier mit
der spd zwei milliarden franken
geld das mit dem verkauf von strom
wieder eingefahren werden sollte die
branche hofft auf gute geschäfte
seit mehrere vorteile ist natürlich dass
sie mal brocken ist der poker womit
jürgen der wassermann genügend fälle
überhaupt in der lage ist beim spiel des
auftakts installieren
zweiter vorteil ist dass sie zahlt doch
er 37 ist mittel für europa mit großer
zentralbanken ist das schwitzen relativ
leicht kann man die großindustrie die eu
wird sich den zugang zu den neuen
schweizer strom speichern sichern und
strom durch die schweiz leiten deshalb
hat sie ein interesse an einem vertrag
mit der schweiz
doch der zuständige eu-kommissar beharrt
auf neuen regeln nicht nur für das
stromabkommen
da wir derzeit auf dem weg sind den
eu-binnenmarkt zu vollenden und dafür
entsprechende europäische gesetze haben
die jetzt in den mitgliedsstaaten
umgesetzt oder in der praxis angewandt
werden müssen ist der zeitpunkt ideal
dass die schweiz sich in den binnenmarkt
einbringen geht es ein paar
grundsätzliche fragen zum beispiel
gerichtsbarkeit oder wenn europa in fünf
jahren seine binnenmarktregeln
fortschreibt ergänzt wir das dann in der
schweiz fortgeschrieben und ergänzt beim
strom abkommen mit der eu geht es auch
für die schweiz um viel
es ist für die schweizer energiezukunft
zentral betont der bundesrat betonen
auch die wirtschaftsvertreter
strom haben das abkommen mit europäische
union tag ist das schlüsselelement für
der ganze energiestrategie wo jetzt der
bundesrat von ebensee hat ohne dass es
uns gelingt den diskriminierungsfreien
bestandteil werte von europäischen
strommarkt und so findet die
energiewende so wie sie der bundesrat es
bleibt einfach nicht statt und zu wird
erneut ein wirtschaftsabkommen zum
politikum
an der ersten august feier im
aargauischen reinach in diesem sommer 20
jahre nach dem ewr nein begann die svp
begann christoph blocher seine neue anti
europa kampagne
und hier spielt das stromabkommen eine
entscheidende rolle wenn er so viel vor
dem strom ab da sie liebt einige nur zum
stromabkommen jaja stromabkommen
strommarkt und da hinteren rücken
daneben um vertrag bis und schweiz
abschluss sie drehung ist und das ist
sie im stromberger bundesrat der eu wie
teilt wir sind bereit das künftige
eu-recht zu übernehmen
alles was jetzt flüsse werden auf dem
gewissen und ein mit mir und für alle
anderen verträge um ihre zuflüsse machen
was klären die rhetorik von heute
gleicht derjenigen von damals im
unterschied zu damals ist die
bevölkerung eu-skeptische geworden und
der bundesrat verfolgt das beitritts
ziel nicht mehr
christoph blocher ziel dennoch auf diese
vermischung und er hat es geschafft dass
die vergangenheit mit voller wucht
zurückgekehrt ist die staatspolitischen
fragen die vor 20 jahren nicht gelöst
wurden führen erneut zur
innenpolitischen zerreißprobe damals sei
der bundesrat keinen anderen ausweg als
einen vollbeitritt das beitrittsgesuch
wurde bis heute nicht zurück genommen
dass wir das gesuch um aufnahme von
handlungen gerecht das hätte es wieder
hin
es stand b in brüssel oder sagen wir
schuhe im zimmer in brüssel
mögliche mission in dearborn mit
der etat wurde die konferenz sei also
standpunkt keine tage mir hat das
orientiert mir hätte es als also einen
interessanten partner auch ein bisschen
anders behandelt wird als wenn man gut
hätte gemacht und das uns bemüht 20
jahre später muss man das und aussagen
zum darf man das gesuch nicht
zurückziehen das ist einfach das was die
politik muss machen sie muss immer der
plan b im sack und da vorne spielen
das zeitfenster aufgeben
20 jahre nach dem evian einbeziehen
erster parteien bestellung und hätte
wird diskutieren über ewe woche betritt
ist und nicht über die besonders eine
grafik alternativ wäre nach wie vor die
sache ohne tabu diskutiert er mit dem
schweizer volk mal die frage erneut
unterbreiten und sage was sind die vor
und nachteile offen und dabei aber dafür
muss ein eu-beitrittsgesuch von damals
jean pascal delamuraz felber von damals
zurückziehen und die gegner von einst
formieren sich wieder
sie feiern den sieg von damals mit
historischen uniformen und mit
böllerschüssen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schießen feiern sich mut machen als ob
der kampf gegen einen eu-beitritt kurz
bevorstünde
[Musik]
gerade war einem zukunftsprojekt dem
stromabkommen kehren die geister von
einst zurück
sonnenenergie windenergie strom für
europa zu jeder zeit verfügbar
für die stromwirtschaft geht es um
nichts geringeres als um den anschluss
an die zukunft ermöglicht dass wir die
richtigen motor anbieten also sehr rast
in asien produzieren was mir das
ungehindert und diskriminierungsfreie
ich glaube ich mache wie ich wie andere
stromproduzent in ganz europa das buch
das abkommen das mir kann zu beschützen
die richtige verbringen
in der schweiz wird schon gebaut
der staudamm am oberen speichersee
enorme trance wird um circa 20 meter
erhöht ab 2017 kann er doppelt so viel
wasser gespeichert werden wie bis anhin
[Musik]
die stromwirtschaft drängt auf einen
vertrag mit der eu die eu will ihn
ebenfalls
doch nur in neuer form
wie vor 20 jahren wird ein wirtschafts
vertrag zum politikum
stellvertretend für etwas viel größeres
denn letztlich geht es um die frage der
selbstbestimmung sogar der ewe erhöht
jetzt als politisches projekt neu
diskutiert
wohne ich danke das ist es wirtschaft
und das industrie abkommens notwendig
ist bin ich hatte meine dass das
langfristig für wesentliche vorteil
bringt somit potenzierung in euro
metzmacher will das im für mich beides
nicht souveränitäts element wo der kern
von der schweiz macht ich fühle mich als
schweizer als autonome schweizer als
stolzer schweizer genauso vertreten
wenn ich mitglied von iwf und eu will
der weltweit lösung für den
institutionellen probleme und zwar alles
was sie zeigt zwei jahren bewertet das
heißt wenn schweiz entstanden ist
zusammen mit brüssel dpa in der eu
werden die schweizer vorschläge bereits
abgelehnt
sie besteht auf dem rahmenabkommen für
alle bilateralen verträge auflösungen
wie im e wr
die verhandlungen dürften sich hinziehen
20 jahre lang herrschte ruhe
nun stehen der schweiz wieder unruhige
zeiten bevor
eine einfache antwort gibt es nicht die
1992 geht es um grundsätzliches welche
beziehungen will die schweiz in zukunft
mit den nachbarn mit der eu pflegen wie
weit will sie dafür ein stück ihrer
souveränität opfern um ein anderes zu
wahren es geht um die identität und
dabei treffen welten aufeinander
damals wie heute geht es um die eine
unbeantwortete frage die frage nach dem
rechten weg
[Musik]